well the cincinnati bengals have
reunited quarterback joe burrow with
receiver jamar chase chase the fifth
overall pick in the 2021 draft a little
bit of a gutsy move by the bengals had a
bad experience with john ross four years
ago ninth overall pick last guy taken
before patrick mahomes he's now gone
he's a giant chase is a bengal and he
really is the best receiver in the group
he didn't play last year the opt out
clearly not hurting him he's an elite
player knowing joe burrow didn't hurt
either burrow in position to surely put
in a good word with the coaching staff
the front office about his teammate they
were electric together at lsu now they
get a chance to be electric together
again with the bengals in those new
uniforms assuming borough is ready to go
come week one but regardless of who the
quarterback is they have a great
receiver now and they have a great
receiving core and a great running back
in joe mixon this could be a high-end
offense ready to compete
both in the in the afc north and with
some of the best teams in the afc again
if pro or is healthy and if chase ends
up being as good as advertised
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports